hey youtubers it's Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions on my
Game of Thrones queue a very
controversial episode I you know on a
scale from
twincest to red wedding I would rate
this at like bail or set from last year
I also saw there were some questions
about the schedule because usually
there's like a break in episodes there's
been a week where the show doesn't air
in previous seasons that's not the case
this year there's not gonna be any break
so next week we'll be Episode seven so
just careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet so
here go on to questions Michael asks in
the sand snakes fight scene bran gets
his arm nicked do you think that he got
poisoned yeah I mean I had to rewatch it
but yeah it definitely looked like he
got nicked I think you know if they want
us to think that he's going to die
they'll show us in next week's episode I
did check the IMDB list for the cast for
the next couple of episodes bran isn't
listed on the cast but that might just
be an error if you remember when
Barristan Selmy died he still appeared
in the next episode like we saw the body
at the end of this week's episode bran
was still making fun of the sand snakes
he was still cracking jokes so if he's
going to die they have to follow up on
that they can't just not bring him back
he was nicked by tieying's dagger she's
known for working with poisons just like
her father Oberyn Martell so you know
you do the math he probably got poisoned
it's nothing close to the level of
poison that the mountain took in but you
remember that I mean the mountain is
enormous for those either actually
really enjoy Braun's song when he was
singing in the episode Jerome Flynn is
actually a famous musician in the UK so
that's why he's such a good singer next
question Justin asks a question about
the Hall of faces what are the odds that
wearing a face someone would run into
someone else that knew that person but
whenever a faceless person takes a new
face they take a new identity so they
would probably just fake it
they seem pretty knowledgeable too so
like if they were going on a mission
they probably pick a face that they knew
wouldn't be recognized but there's no
accounting for random chance so you know
if they did run into someone that knew
the face that they were wearing they
would just pretend to be that person it
hasn't really come up on the show but
these are the most skilled assassins in
the world so they're really good at
pretending to be other people
Georgia are Martin actually added some
context to the the faceless people
changing a faces to there is a certain
level of sorcery involved but it really
hasn't been explained in great detail
yet so hopefully they'll spell that out
in future
episodes sometimes Martin isn't really
explicit with the way certain techniques
work usually he's pretty good about
answering questions though when you ask
him a convention so if you ever do run
into him at a convention you get the
chance you can ask him any question you
want he'll probably answer it except for
who is Jon Snow's mother next question
Joanna asks I seldom find fault with
Game of Thrones but the sand snakes
Bronn and Jamie fight was weak and a
tiny bit out of sync yeah I think you
know I was really surprised mostly with
the speed with which they move through
that Queen Maker storyline my guess is
is that they didn't want to do the arian
Martell part of that story so they just
kind of blew right through that the big
question now is is what is Jamie going
to do now that he is in Dorne is he
gonna go right back to King's Landing or
are we gonna see a left turn for the
character but remember Prince Doran
doesn't hate Jamie like he's not gonna
execute him or anything he doesn't want
to start a war with King's Landing so
he's not gonna do anything harsh one of
the other common complaints I saw you
know about the the Doran storyline this
week was you know by how convenient
everything seemed like they all just
happened to converge on that one little
garden in such a quick amount of time
the water gardens themselves are
actually a pretty big place there are a
number of gardens it's not just like one
little water garden they probably had to
speed things along just because of where
they wanted to take Jamie's character
this season
like they didn't have that many episodes
to deal with this plotline next question
Kaiser asks why doesn't Theon stab
Ramsay in the back and save Sansa why I
think that you know they want to tease
his arc out a little bit more I think
they're doing Theon like right out of
the books the writers of the episode
clarified that what's going on this
season is they're doing Ramsay's
storyline not so much Sansa storyline so
all this Winterfell stuff is built
around Ramsay in the books they just
replaced fake Arya with Sansa because
they had a lead actress that was in the
Vale and Sansa storyline in the books
just not not a whole lot happens once
she gets to the Vale and they couldn't
have a main actress do nothing for an
entire season so the choice they made
was to put Sansa in that Ramsay
storyline just because you're so
invested in the character think they
wanted to ratchet up the WTF and they
they felt like that was a good way to do
it the funny thing about that is is that
you could imply that because bran is
completely out of the storyline they
don't view him as a main character
because he is literally doing nothing
this season next question though Pratt
asks now that Arya is learning to wear
faces will we see very little
of Maisie Williams well actually that
whole scene with jaqen was about her not
being ready to become no.1 so I don't
think she's gonna be wearing any faces
the actors will be wearing a new costume
she was on the cover of Entertainment
Weekly it's just like a different
costume but it's still Maisie Williams
based on George R Martin clarifying you
know like the faceless men's technique
it seems like that is something that
they learned over a long period of time
something that's very difficult to learn
to wear other faces so I don't expect to
aria to do that anytime soon and you
know one of the issues too is is they
would literally have to change the
identity of one of their main actors and
I don't think that the show would do
that next question Adam asks since the
wedding took place near the heart tree
did the three-eyed Ravens see them and
so did bran technically you could say
that we really don't have any idea
what's going on with bran right now he
essentially is like at the end of his
dance with dragons storyline he's in the
middle of learning all about the powers
of greensight so no matter when that
wedding took place he'd be able to see
it but if that's the case you know
because brains not around we won't find
out about it till next season whatever
he comes back next question boo Cooley
asks do you think that aria can ever
actually become no.1 well I you know I
don't think that she'll ever fully
become like jack in the car but I do
think that she'll get really badass Arie
is one of those storylines that I think
is gonna stay pretty close to what it is
in the books you know just with some
small omissions I mean they're speeding
it along pretty fast so if you want to
see what that's going just you know
reread her dance with dragons chapters
and her winds of winter preview there's
a sample POV chapter of hers from winds
of winter that George R Martin posted
next question top shelf asks so what
happens if Tommen is found out if he is
all Lannister who would they make the
King with the faith takeover well they
would basically you know like if Tommen
were found out they would depend on
whether or not the Lords of the realm
supported the faced decision to take him
out of office there are a number of
different things that could happen you
know they could appoint a temporary
regent until they figured things out if
the Lords that were loyal to the crown
didn't support the faith then they would
probably try to suppress the high
Sparrow that's a whole lot of what-ifs
though I mean they would have to have
definitive proof for the whole realm to
support the faced decision a long time
ago in a Song of Ice and Fire like you
know predating the the current storyline
there was a faith militant uprising in
the Targaryen King
the time to suppress them so just
because the faith seems like it's going
a little nuts you know the faith
militants going a little crazy all over
King's Landing doesn't mean that the
rest of the realm won't rat like to
suppress them if need be so big
decisions like deciding who is going to
be king or really only decided by the
victor next question Steven asks have
D&D drop Theon sister from the story no
not entirely I know it seems like they
drop the Ironborn but you're a Greyjoy
is on the cast list for next week's
episode I think what they'll do is
they'll weave her book story in with the
changes they've already made so I'm not
expecting a whole lot more Ironborn
stuff but more Theon sister you know
kind of getting roped in with Deion's
storyline this year next question Wes
asks why haven't we seen bran this
season and what do you predict will
happen because that the three-eyed raven
said you will not walk again but you
will fly well they're just doing his
book story so I think he'll show up
again in season 6 when there's a you
know a little bit more war making going
on in the north his storyline has this
really supernatural context so I think
you know once we get into more white
Walker territory he'll show up again
I don't think we'll start seeing shades
of that till we get to hardhome this
season spilling into season six thank
you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do there is a rumor about the title
of the finale supposedly is that the
title is just winter but that's
unconfirmed as in winter has come I do
think that that would be an awesome
moment to end on you know it's like some
big WTF drop to black it was snowing
whenever Sansa put her wedding dress on
like you could see snow falling outside
the window at Winterfell but typically
you know like winter has come is
typically like when it really starts
snowing in the north and it actually you
start to see snow as far south as King's
Landing that's when it's like WTF winter
has come where we are in the storyline
it is about the right time it just it
depends on how fast they want to speed
through books 4 & 5 I do think we'll end
season 5 having seen most of the big WTF
from book five books 4 & 5 em because
they're both concurrent but
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Sara MS you and a HBO now
subscription just be sure to DM me on
the back end of my channel so I get your
contact info next week like I said there
isn't gonna be a break we'll get episode
7 so be sure to subscribe to get that
video I'll be interested to see you know
how they follow up the WTF from this
episode I think we all want to see like
where Sansa is going to be mentally next
week
the title of this week's episode was
unbowed unbent unbroken the house
Martell motto but the titles of the
episodes apply to all of the storylines
in an episode so I think that's meant to
imply that Sansa will remain unbroken
despite the treatment that's been given
to her and because it's called the gift
in that and that's an area in the north
I think we'll find out a little bit more
about what's going on with Brienne and
the other people around Winterfell so I
will be posting a new bonus video before
next week's episode if you guys have any
special requests just leave them in the
comments in case you haven't seen it I
did post a bonus video all about the
Targaryen restoration on the show and
some of the changes from the books you
can click here to watch that and you can
click here for my episode 6 video if you
haven't seen it yet thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]
you